if a filmmaker is looking to secure
locations especially here in Los Angeles
where oftentimes you need permits and
then often cost a lot of money do you
have any sort of advice or anything you
would tell like other filmmakers looking
to grab locations on the fly or even
before hand in pre-production yeah
exactly okay um that depends a lot of
that can I know in New York it's
different okay but I'm not sure how it
works here but if you have you know if
your friend I've walked into businesses
and just started talking to the owner in
New York and I walked into a theater
movie theater and got my first film
shown in a big movie theater despite
building relationships and tell it on my
story down on my situation and the worst
I've ever gotten told was we need to get
insurance you know and I'm sure in la
they're gonna be like because I know
they can charge you a lot you know but
there's always you know if that's the
situation go to the next door you know
if he depends on your budget I guess if
you have some money to work with money
can get done anything done almost but I
was always operating even when I had a
lot of money to work with I was always
operating on trying to save money so if
I get something done for little money
I'm gonna do it I don't just throw money
at problems I tried to work the problem
out and by making everybody a part of
the project and that's why I would have
owners of buildings excited about the
movie and then become friends with them
because it's to me it's you know it's
not just about going to a location and
you know if I got the money paddled
enough money I would just send someone
out the locations what I call it a
Scouter a location scout that's good to
have you know and I had a friend of mine
that works for the soprano that did that
but we weren't acting with that type of
fund and when you would go into these
you know movie shops or
bronze wherever you're going into would
you have something to show them or
literally it would just be you going in
to talk to the owner plummet a musician
okay so I played a lot of bars okay and
I knew a lot of these bar owners and bar
owners know a lot of people okay and
they know a lot of people in the
business and in different types of
business and you know so it's just
networking and talking to people so I
would go in there talking to people had
already knew people that didn't already
know I would tell them who I had
involved in the project if I had and I
learned early on in my career as a
musician working with names helps you a
lot you know so in this case you know
you may you may lead us out i'm doing a
movie I have Steve Guttenberg attached
and then that would kind of open the
door a little bit more especially in
yeah yeah exactly yeah that's what
happened and then you know we'd start
talking from there and they said can you
make sure our our sign gets put in the
movie and once your new secret the duck
you'll see a lot of this bar in the
movie so
you